welcome back this is the ben shapiro
shower number a five five two three six
thirty two twenty eight that is eighty
five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight Karen calling from Hilo
Hawaii how are you doing Karen go for it
hello hello how are you
am I really talking to Ben Shapiro you
are indeed I am here you have reached me
well I've been a faithful reader of
yours and listener of your clips and
everything that come on Facebook and I
can't believe I'm actually talking to
you well I appreciate it thank you so
much so what's on your mind well I mean
I live in Hawaii were a little bit off
from what's going on on the mainland but
I guess I just don't understand why
President Trump has not put a kibosh on
all of what's been going on the looting
the rioting the law lawlessness and so I
was wondering your take on that it just
had left me kind of with a lot of
questions yeah I mean I think that the
answer is that honestly the first line
of defense in all these cases in the
mayor is the mayor and the governor but
the president acted late on this and I
think everyone every Republican knows
this I mean for a week the president
basically sat in the basement and
tweeted and everybody who was on the
right was going wait a second here is
captain macho over here who's constantly
saying he's gonna be law and order a guy
and tweeting law and order ain't gonna
do it right and Coulter was tweeting out
you know in the middle of these rides
maybe he'll tweet again a at some point
the president was supposed to come out
like the first 24 hours and say we
understand that police brutality is
something that we all want to want to
curb and stop the American police are
not systemic ly racist they are not bad
people they're the vast majority of them
are heroes and if there's rioting and
looting I'm making all resources of the
federal government available to mayors
and and to governors and if this crap
doesn't stop inside 72 hours then I'm
invoking the insurrection act because
our major cities cannot be curfew or
burned this is insane like that's what
people were waiting for that sort of
strong action and he didn't take that
action
now the riots and the looting seem to
calm down for the most part and if you
look at states like Georgia obviously
the governor of Georgia is Republican
Brian Kemp and so if there's rioting in
Atlanta then first first opportunity to
do something about it goes to the
Republican governor but you know as far
as like Washington State in Seattle
at some point the president probably is
going to have to do something there I
mean if the Washington got or or at the
very least you should be out there
saying why isn't the Washington like my
federal troops are right here I've got
the National Guard right here why is the
Washington governor like why is Trump
not making an issue of this is really
it's political malpractice frankly we
got a country that is rife with rioting
and looting for a week and then it sort
of dies down and then you have an entire
new republic set up in the center of
Seattle and the president has his
campaign this is his campaign would you
like chaos would you like what the
Democrats are selling you here because
the last several weeks have been
democratic governance to the nines are
you really enjoying this and instead the
president is like tweeting about how he
doesn't like John Bolton I just its
malpractice its political malpractice
exactly I've been feeling the same way
it's kind of left me a lot of questions
about the next election cycle and yeah I
mean listen I think a lot of Republicans
will end up coming home right a lot of
Republicans will say listen at least it
ain't gonna be Biden right the
democratic governance here is that but
our people like pumped to go to the
polls is the enthusiasm super high right
now I would say not I mean I've been
seeing people who have been longtime
Trump fans who are who are saying like
where is he this is not what we what we
bargained for like all of his chief
again that doesn't mean that you
shouldn't vote for him I'm planning on
voting for him but it does mean that the
the idea that that Trump has got his
base solidly behind him at this point
that is not what the polls are showing
and that is dangerous for him he is
trailing in nearly every swing state
he's running dead even in places like
Texas if we get these kind of results
it's a disaster for him and his ass for
the Republican Party he lose Arizona he
could lose in North Caroline in Arizona
he's trailing in North Carolina he's
trailing in Florida he's now trailing in
Michigan he is trailing in Pennsylvania
he's trailing in Wisconsin and he's
running dead even
maybe trailing in Ohio I mean those are
bad bad results you lose the Senate and
you lose the presidency to the Democrats
and things get extraordinarily ugly yeah
I mean I don't mean to be depressing but
this is why he has to do a better job he
cannot do this I appreciate the call
Karen and I hope you're at least
enjoying the pandemic life over in
Hawaii I mean you're gonna be locked
down anywhere it seems like Hawaii might
not be a bad place to go we're doing
really well with Kovac so we're we're
awesome on that and our beaches are open
in our Park so it's awesome okay well
that is good that is good
I appreciate it Karen
thanks so much for calling Deandra in
California on the bench Bureau she'll go
for Andrew hey Ben you hear me I can
hear you just fine hey so just real
quick I'm a law enforcement officer in
California and that has had a quick
question that's when I say that I love
your work and what you do and do you I
don't you heard about the Bakersfield
police officer that's on admin leave
over a photo that was from a yearbook in
High School where he wore black bass I'm
nothing that's right but this is what
happened when he was in high school and
it obviously wasn't deemed racist at the
time or offensive at the time you know
as Jimmy Fallon and Robert Downey jr.
have done have done things like this but
now he's being disciplined now like yeah
that's crazy but obviously it's
absolutely craziness I mean one of the
one of the keys to America's criminal
justice system is the idea that even if
you commit a violent crime when you're
under 18 we what we basically wiped the
record clean right your juvie records
are sealed hey nobody knows that you
committed a crime and you committed a
crime when you're 15 you go to juvie so
if you if you commit an armed robbery
when you're 14 years old your record is
essentially expunged by the time you
become an adult right nobody knows about
your juvenile record if you have a
yearbook photo a bad your book photo
when you are 15 years old then we will
bring that up 15 years later and then
we'll fire you from a police force
implying that you are a racist even if
your record shows no evidence of actual
racial mistreatment it's absurd it's an
absurdity and this is why call out
culture is so ugly and so bad because
here's the deal when the puritans get
going and when they decide to uncover
all sin and when the only things that
are deemed sins our sins by one
particular class of people because one
of the things that we have gotten from
the left is that no one on the left can
be racist and particularly racial
minorities it's impossible for them to
be racist right this is why they've
redefined the term racism to mean racism
plus power right that's how they can say
well you know here's it here's a Louis
Farrakhan being wildly honest medic he's
not actually in Semitic is that actually
a bigot because Louis Farrakhan is a
black person and so he doesn't have
power and if somebody if al Sharpton
says
horrible things about white people
that's totally it's not racism because
well Sharpton doesn't have power which
of course is completely untrue I mean he
was a regular visitor at the Obama White
House the
the notion that racism only runs in one
direction or that a bad yearbook photo
when you are 15 years old is indicative
of a deep-seated racism that can never
be removed from you or that you're to be
held accountable frankly for anything
you said or did when you are a hormonal
teenager popping your pimples and
waiting at a first date
it's absurdity at the highest level
Andrew and it's making for an unlivable
country you're actually gonna end up
with more polarization if you feel like
you're living in an area where your your
book photo is going to be brought up as
an excuse to fire you from your job
you're just gonna move you're just gonna
leave you're not gonna live there
anymore and you're gonna go join a
business where people aren't gonna do
that to you the polarization of American
politics continues to pace the callout
culture is very it's a very bad thing
unless you did something right now that
indicates your career or bad treatment
of other people in which case you can be
called out or if you're a public figure
and you can be called out the idea that
we're gonna resurface your Halloween
costume from 1832 and then we'll be like
oh well now and that means you should be
fired as a cop in Bakersfield oh come on
it's absurd and I think people are tired
of it I think there will be a backlash I
just don't know when it's gonna come and
I think that unfortunately president
Trump has um president Trump has not
been a great vehicle for the backlash I
think that he was the vehicle of the
backlash in 2016 but I think that
because he's so fragmented and because
he is so diffused in his response and
non-exact in his response like you hear
Attica Lee he should be the guy right he
is the I am the breaker of politically
correct chains he's the breaker of
chains right he's the queen of dragons
when it comes to this sort of stuff but
he's too busy like yelling it at John
Bolton to do anything about it that's
very frustrating so and it seems like a
radical less either want us cops either
dead heck or in handcuffs or he's been
fired and I feel like it's I don't know
if this is true the pendulum is too far
moved at it can it change and also we
know we're always told and you know that
the family majorities for us and they're
gonna bet but why are they styling
why aren't why aren't people just out
because they're afraid they're gonna get
fired I mean it's not just about the
cops I mean I was talking to a very
prominent person last night a very
prominent person who considers himself a
centrist he's sort of somewhat
conservative and he works at a major
company in a very very high position and
this person said to me this is a direct
quote from last night I'm never gonna
mention this person's names because he
would be fired probably just for talking
to me
he literally
last night if I tweeted out the majority
of the vast majority of cops are heroes
if I tweeted that out I would lose my
job that's that that is the way that
American society is working right now
and that's why the silent majority is
silent they're not afraid to speak up on
behalf of cops they're afraid they're
gonna lose their job if they speak up on
behalf of cops which is why eventually
what's going to happen is the
conservative employers will be the
places that employ conservatives that's
what's gonna happen is you'll have
entirely ideologically stratified
companies which is really bad for the
country but it's what the left will on
Chandra I really appreciate the call
Leon saying Columbus Ohio did he talk to
you Leon to Hayden I'm doing really good
Ben it's good to talk to you too um I
wanted to talk to you today about what
you were talking about earlier cancel
culture as a libertarian I believe that
the latest song issues in society is not
new political channels so I feel like
cancel culture is the way to solve those
societal issues through the means of the
market and the market is really
responsive to what the people in society
want so my question is is don't you feel
like at least cancel culture is better
than having people ban hate speech yes
of course absolutely I mean I talk about
in my upcoming book how to destroy
America in three easy steps available
for pre-order right now I in that book I
talk about cancel culture and I make the
obvious point that cancel culture like a
censorious culture is of course a lot
better than having the government
actually regulate speech but de
Tocqueville talked about this going all
the way back to to democracy in America
the idea that you can excise somebody
from polite society and it really can
ruin their life now that power can be
used for good right sometimes that's
actually necessary so you have a racist
cop like an actual racist cop right and
then the cop is caught saying the n-word
to a black suspect and so that person
loses their job and people don't want to
be friends with them like okay okay but
if you're talking about using canceled
culture to the point where like you wore
a costume trying to make fun of megyn
kelly in 2018 in the Washington Post
runs a 3,000 word article on you and
then tries to target you like cancel
that the point is that social pressure
can be used for good or it can be used
for evil I'm very much infinitely on say
I've talked about the fact that I think
social institutions outside government
are really really important like
churches and synagogues I think are
really important why well because they
said social standards and they set
expectations for you so the question is
not whether
whether people are held to standard
socially I think they are and they
should be the question is that cancel
culture has a certain a certain type of
conduct that is canceled and the type of
conduct that is canceled is basically
you said something that offended someone
in 1833 and now we are going to come
after you that's what I objected but
you're right obviously you know in a
social social ostracization is not the
same thing
governmental we speak more from a
libertarian perspective as the
government coming in and cracking down
speech surgery and thank you Ben I
appreciate Leon say thanks for the call
Caleb in Kentucky you're on the bench
for your show for Caleb hey how are you
hanging in there man how are you great
I'm a really huge fan man i watch your
show every day and then I've read
through yearbooks just pre-ordered your
new one how to destroy American three
easy steps and my question for you today
is with so many disputes going between
each country you know India China India
Pakistan Russia China do you think that
in especially with all the economy you
know going down do you think that a war
could arise out of this or do you
foresee any potential Wars I think that
it's unlikely that a war Rises out of
this because China is actually more
interested in economic dominance than
actual physical territorial dominance so
China basically just wants to maintain
its borders and then economically annex
of surrounding nations use the power of
its trade and the power of its
overweening influence in that area of
the world in order to bring countries
into its economic sphere this is what
they're trying to done in to Hong Kong
already they lied and then they
basically you know stealthily took over
the political process there I feel like
they're gonna try to do the same thing
to Taiwan they're gonna try and use
their economic power to try and get a
government elected in Taiwan that's much
more friendly to the Chinese government
I don't think China wants an overt war
with India and I don't think that India
wants an overt war with China because
that would be obviously unbelievably
deadly you're talking about two nuclear
powers that are the two most populous
nations on earth India and Pakistan have
gone out at 1,000 times since the
division of India and Pakistan back in
the 1940s particularly over Kashmir it's
never erupted into a full-scale war and
it seems like that would be much riper
for a full-scale war than India China
like I think that it'll be weapons down
and I think that this will be you know I
think this will move be move beyond if
there's going to be you know another
world war it has to be such a conflict
divisions that imply
case a series of alliances they you end
up in a world war like let's say that
India and China went to war do you think
the United States would jump in I mean
pretty pretty certain not it seems very
doubtful that Europe would jump in so
that the the world wars that we've seen
before our times when you have actual
alliances that are violated right China
China attacking like in an over American
ally with whom we have a mutual defense
treaty is is a sort of demand we were
there I appreciate the call Caleb yeah
thanks so much I wouldn't worry about
nuclear annihilation just yet we're
gonna take more of your calls in just
one second at eight five five two three
six thirty two twenty eight eight five
five two three six thirty two twenty
eight this is the Ben Shapiro show